gérard larcher le président du sénat est
l'invité de preuves par 3 bonsoir ouais
merci d'être avec nous donc pour ce
rendez-vous de public sénat avec l'
agence france-presse et dailymotion avec
moi ce soir pour vous interroger jean
louis prévost de la sp et bien sûr
perrine tarneaud de public sénat
françois hollande à mi-mandat votre
jugement les réformes à l'épreuve du
sénat de droite mais aussi les réformes
du sénat que vous allez entreprendre
l'ump l'ump en pleine compétition
interne autant de sujets bien sûr sur
lesquels nous attendons vos réponses
gérard larcher d'abord le chef de l'état
donc confronté à son bilan de mi-mandat
le jugement des français est sévère
iriez-vous jusqu'à dire d'ores et déjà
que le quinquennat et raté à tous les
cas la première moitié du quinquennat
n'apparaît pas comme une réussite et
c'est plutôt 100% échec et quand on voit
ce soir ce que bruxelles vient de faire
comme observations sur les projections
budgétaires et de voir que notre déficit
budgétaire va encore s'aggraver en 2015
mais encore plus en 2016 nous disons que
ce qui a été dit par le président de la
république ses engagements je pense
notamment à la promesse de l'inversion
du chômage qui est si sensible je peux
vous garantir pour avoir parcouru la
france pendant des semaines et des
semaines que c'est le premier sujet est
bien là dessus c'est un échec total et
en même temps à désarroi extraordinaire
et aujourd'hui ces mêmes l'état de droit
dont on a le sentiment au travers d'un
dossier aussi dramatique aussi
douloureux que le dossier du barrage
dans le tarn est bien de devoir état de
droit sandales et aussi parce que parce
que au fond on a le sentiment que l'état
n'assume pas pleinement les fondamentaux
républicains
alors bien sûr on a un ministre de
l'intérieur dont je tiens à saluer avec
respect l'action et l'engagement on est
aussi fasse un drame humain avec la mort
d'un jeune et en même temps on voit un
conseiller de l'elysée distinguer entre
légalité légitimité là c'est nicolas
hulot qui oppose la légalité donc des
enquêtes publiques élus locaux à l'aller
l'itc que la légimité autant de
l'environnement d'environnement qu'est
ce que cette légitimité là elle doit
avoir des fondements scientifiques et
est-ce qu'on imagine qu'en 25 ans de
projets on n'a pas examiné un certain
nombre de ses fondements nous avons
besoin d'y voir clair y compris dans les
règles d'urbanisme dans les règles
d'aménagement il ya aussi des réalités
on a parfois présentés de manière
caricaturale d'agriculture du tarn j'ai
été dans le tarn pendant la campagne
sénatoriale est ce que vous croyez dans
cette région qu'ont et la façade est
immense culture céréalière on est là sur
des polypes petit polyculteur une
moyenne de 40 hectares un problème d'eau
qui est un problème évident en
andalousie la préservation des espaces
mais bien sûr c'est qu'on sait quelque
chose d'important je me suis battue
comme élu local pour la préservation des
espaces subite mais on débat d'un
hectare et demi je dis pas qu'un hectare
et demi ça n'est pas important mais ça
ne mérite pas la mort d'un jeune et ça
ne mérite pas la remise en cause d'un
état de l'état d'objet vous aller encore
plus loin que certains comme à la gpao
nicolas sarkozy qui parle d' échec sur
échec au d'échec du quinquennat mais
mandat vous vous dites que on n'est plus
dans un état de droit non je dis pas ça
je dis que c'est l'état de droit qui est
fragilisée regarder les scènes qui sont
déroulés ce week-end et vous voyez bien
que la question de l'état de droit il
compris quand je vois un certain nombre
d'intellectuels
s'exprimer pour remettre en cause cet
état de droit je crois fondamentalement
à la république
moi je suis respectueux du président de
la république de sa fonction je suis
respectueux du gouvernement ça ne
m'empêche pas de le combattre mais dans
mon attitude d'opposition constructive
c'est dire aussi nous devons ensemble
sortir le pays de la crise morale de la
crise de désarroi et nous ne pouvons pas
le faire dans une république sans
réaffirmer l'importance de leurs droits
qu'attendez vous donc de françois
hollande il sera jeudi sur la télévision
d'abord donc si on vous suit une
manifestation d'autorité permettez moi
une petite remarque sur la réunion que
madame royal va tenir ce soir je suis
très étonné comme président du sénat
donc d'une des deux assemblées du
parlement
par exemple hormis le président du
conseil général ce qui est naturel que
le sénateur du tarn philippe
bonnecarrère ne sois pas invitée à cette
réunion que le député de la
circonscription où est en train d'ériger
ce barrage ne soit pas hésité à la
réunion comme si des parlementaires qui
dans un état de droit représente la
population les territoires n'avait pas
j'allais dire leur mot à dire dans une
décision qui doit être prise lors du
président de la république point
jeunesse du président de la république
aurait fait face à cette fragilisation
des nouveaux de l'état de droit en
france avec ans j'ai rencontré le
président de la république et je
respecte éminemment la fonction le 3
octobre dernier je lui ai fait état du
désarroi dentelle je sentais pays et je
pense que face à ce désarroi notre
attitude les uns et les autres ce n'est
pas de l'aggraver voilà pourquoi les
déclarations de madame duflot ne sont
particulièrement déplacées et que je les
juge en quelque sorte hors de mon champ
des valeurs républicaines mais que oui
parce que vous parlez de cécile duflot
hors du champ républicain hors des
valeurs républicaines et le canada et
public doit réaffirmer elle a joué le
rôle de boue de faisons oui pas
simplement debout de feu on ne peut pas
dire y compris dans des questions
d'actualité à l'assemblée nationale
jouer et j'allais dire sur un drame
parce que la perte d'un enfant la mort
d'un gène c'est un drame absolu et quand
on a connu de manière plus personnelle
ce genre de drame et bien je peux vous
dire qu'on ne joue pas avec ça y compris
pour tenter j'allais dire de s'attirer
quelques attentions voilà pourquoi alors
les grands le président de la république
parlera jeudi soir souhaitera restaurer
l'état de droit il nous trouvera ses
côtés ça m'apparaît important est que
doit-il faire lui qu est ce qu est ce qu
il peut annoncer qu'est ce que vous
attendez la première des choses puisque
nous avons parlé beaucoup d'état de
droit c'est que le président de la
république doit indiquer les voies du
redressement du pays les voies du
redressement du pays s'est retrouvé le
chemin de la croissance c'est le courage
de réformer or nous avons des signaux
dans tous les sens la semaine dernière
la taxe sur les dividendes des
entreprises supprimés après 48 heures
aujourd'hui même nous avons une annonce
d'une taxe au bénéfice des élus co sur
les résidences secondaires manière
j'allais dire d'achever l'immobilier
déjà bien entamée par les lois de madame
duflot il faut que le président de la
république et le courage de montrer la
voie et d'engager un certain nombre de
réformes dont notre pays a besoin
première des réformes c'est de retrouver
la compétitivité rôle sa personne ya des
choses qui sont engagés bien sûr il ya
des compétitions et son camp sur ce
thème là mais ça n'est pas suffisant ça
n'est pas suffisant et les messages
contradictoires font bien plus de dégâts
que l'on imagine parce que c'est une
partie dans la tête des gens au fond est
ce qu on fait confiance à l'entreprise
ont parlé d'un pacte de responsabilité
souvenez-vous j'ai dis pas la preuve par
3 mai sur le plateau de public sénat il
ya des mois qu'il fallait un pacte de
confiance avec des entreprises ce pacte
de confiance c'est dire allez
gouvernement essaye d'obtenir il a fait
à des gestes conséquent des dizaines de
milliards d'euros que la confiance
comment voulez vous qu'il soit compris
par des chefs d'entreprise quand vous
envoyez les contres signaux comme la
semaine dernière de taxer les dividendes
ce sont des contres signaux absolue le
pacte de confiance ça doit être j'admire
un ensemble de signaux qui dit aux
entreprises on vous aide à retrouver le
chemin de la croissance de la
compétitivité en mille temps aux
salariés de les accompagner voilà
pourquoi je pense que la flexibilité
doit s'accompagner de sécurité est ce
que le patron du medef jouent vraiment
le jeu selon vous pierre gattaz qui
chaque jour ou presque réclament de
nouvelles mesures par exemple la fin de
la justification des licenciements la
volt suivez ou est ce que dans la femme
et justification des licenciements il va
me faire c'est le fameux contrat unique
le fameux contrat indique que jean
tirole d'ailleurs le prénom elle a
imaginé un sujet très manuel valls est
aussi là c'est un sujet très complexe
moi même j'ai été séduit par le contrat
munich mais est ce qu on a mesuré
jalili a
complètement les conséquences juridiques
du contrat l'idée qu'on vous êtes dans
les pays qui ont un seul contrat de
travail on a inventé pour la flexibilité
dans les entreprises d'autres contrats
il ya très très peu de pays qu'on le
contrat unis seule particularité que
nous avons c'est la distinction cdd cdi
chez nous mais est ce qu'on peut
imaginer qu'on se sépare de quelqu'un
sans justifier le licenciement réponse
est non la réponse ce n'est pas possible
parce que l'on retrouvait pour le gall
darwin nuit à l'image du patronat n'ont
mordu à rennes à l'image du patronat il
exprime simplement ce que ressentent
notamment un certain nombre de petits
patrons dans le pays qui sont découragés
quand vous voyez l'état du bâtiment des
travaux publics
l'absence de commandes la situation de
l'immobilier que nous évoquions la
diminution très forte qui vaille celle
de la commande publique dans les
collectivités territoriales comment
voulez vous qu'il n'y ait pas ce
désarroi au niveau des entreprises alors
le désarroi est également politique
certains dans l'opposition marine le pen
la première dit que la dissolution est
inévitable c'est ce que dit également un
françois bayrou est ce que vous pensez
que c'est la seule option qui peut sauf
fréha au chef de l'état dans les mois
qui viennent pour le gaulliste que je
suis la dissolution d'un parti au
président de la république et à lui seul
c'est à lui de juger s'il considère que
la situation politique dans le pays
nécessite de revendre n'est pas
inévitable ouvrir pour l'assemblée
nationale devant les électeurs et
d'ailleurs la constitution prévoit qu'il
doit consulté pour avis le président de
l'assemblée nationale et le président du
sénat rebonds et bouge on a vous l'avez
vu récemment il n'a pas abordé ce jeu
les vues il ya presque un mois
maintenant je le reverrai oui mais je
pense que
aujourd'hui c'est plutôt un pays en
attente de signaux de la part du
président de la république d'un chemin
et de route et donc générer fornaguera
semestre même s'il y avait des solutions
est ce que la droite devra cohabiter ce
landais je ne me place pas dans cette
hypothèse là j'avais écrit il ya
quelques mois avec bernard accoyer un
ensemble de réticences sur la
cohabitation
mais les situations
imaginaires c'est comme chez molière on
attendra que rapporter les réponses
médicales à propos de françois hollande
encore michel rocard lui a déconseillé
de se représenter et vous coûter j'ai
dit au président de la république que
nous n'appartenons pas la même de
famille de pensée politique et je pense
que
en 2017 si le président de la république
et candidat je ne ferai pas au premier
tour au premier tour de ses soutiens
c'est quelque chose de clair c'est une
décision qui lui appartient là aussi une
vision gaulliste c'est une
responsabilité entre un candidat et le
peuple france alors c'est une confiance
qui doit se déterminer bon on vous
interrogera sur ce qui se passe du côté
de l'ump en vue de 2007 tout à l'heure
avec perrine une question sur le couple
exécutif est ce que vous pensez que le
tandem hollande valls va pouvoir tenir
jusqu'à la fin du quinquennat écoutez on
n'est pas en météo prédictive
donc aujourd'hui il ya un premier
ministre et un gouvernement très allants
sur les réformes que vous évoquez un
instant
peut être allons la fin des seuils ce
super être allons mais encore faut-il
les faire
il ya une différence et on ne l'attend
sur la conduite des réformes vous vous
l'attendez comme président du sénat et
vous dites que nous verrons pas raison
et les verra ce que le projet de loi qu
emmanuel macron présentera notamment
dans la dimension compétitivité des
entreprises dans la dimension
sociale évolution des règles sociales on
verra ce que le gouvernement de monsieur
maestro ump non plus ficelé par des
considérations idéologiques
qui vous empêcherait de voter des
réformes j'ai toujours dit que c'est en
tous les cas je le dis depuis quelques
mois que ma vision du rôle de la
majorité sénatoriale sommes clairement
dans l'opposition mais en même temps
nous sommes là pour contribuer à ce que
le pays aille mieux c'est l'attitude
constructive regardez ce que nous avons
fait la semaine passée sur la réforme
territoriale
nous sommes sortis avec une proposition
cette proposition dans le genre
discuterons avec l'assemblée nationale
en commission mixte paritaire après que
l'assemblée nationale est pratiqué la
deuxième lecture c'est la même chose sur
la récente territoriale que nous verrons
c'est notre attitude dans le projet de
loi de finances il s'agit pas
aujourd'hui de refuser le budget en
première partie et dont 10 m'accorde à
coeur de proposer des économies
d'ailleurs ça répondre à une partie des
observations nous sont faites par la
commission va en parler de tous ces cas
toutes ces réformes là qui viennent
devant le sénat dans l'est dans les
jours et les semaines qui viennent ça va
marcher un mot vous avez eu des mots
aimables pour le ministre de l'intérieur
qui a été un peu car là encore par
cécile
j'ai eu des mots qui considère que
monsieur 15,9 à fait à pleinement
accompli sa fonction de ministre j'ai
mesuré la douleur qui était la sienne
pour avoir été ministre moins aimé avoir
connu le drame de la mort d'un
inspecteur du travail je sais combien ça
peut vous secouer personnellement et ça
dépasse ça fonctionne alors je dis
respect tout simplement si j'utilisais
une formule de jeunes oui respect n'est
pas de ceux à gauche sur tous les cas
qui ont appelé à sa démission mais il
vous a grillé la politesse à cette
semaine un ministre de l'intérieur il
est allé à calais c'est vous qui étiez
attendu écoutez j'ai trouvé que nous
n'étions pas du tout sur le même
registre et que c'était la place du
ministre de l'intérieur d'aller aux airs
et plein art haut niveau moi j'irai
accompagner un maire jetté le 19 février
19 février à calais j'ai pu mesurer la
situation à calais et à date en dix mois
et j'ai mesure l action assez
exceptionnel de notre collègue natacha
bouchart dans cette ville où elle a été
longtemps à bordeaux n'est abandonné
avec des situations qui nécessite du
courage sur les questions migratoires
c'est aussi une ville qui portent des
projets d'avenir c'est une des villes où
le chômage est en train de se réduire je
suis la prostate vous irez donc plus
tard mais aussi pour balan la mairie
dans quelques semaines la maire ump de
l'eure qui s'est dit satisfaite par les
propositions du ministre de l'intérieur
puisqu'il a confirmé qu'il y aurait un
centre de jour 1 qu'elle est ouvert pour
tous ces migrants qui allait ouvrir
bientôt pour tous ces migrants diack on
va donc évoqué maintenant les réformes
au sénat et la réforme du sénat avec
jean luc prévost de la fp d'abord avec
quentin cannes mais voyant les grandes
lignes de ce qui serait part de ce que
vous préparez
sitôt réélu à la tête du sénat gérard
larcher évoque les tâches qui
l'attendent après plusieurs articles de
presse fustigeant la haute-assemblée
coûteuse à quoi sert-elle j'entends que
ce soit collectivement que nous
retrouvions les voies de la confiance de
la confiance des françaises et des
français
le nouveau président fait plusieurs
propositions fait ressortir le sénat de
son palais pour qu'ils se montrent et
enquêtes rendre impossible l'adoption
d'un projet de loi quand trop peu d'élus
sont dans l'hémicycle l'absentéisme un
sujet très sensible qui va de pair avec
l' enveloppe de la réserve parlementaire
allouée aux sénateurs au total 53 9
millions d'euros je travaille
actuellement sur une réforme de la
répartition de la réserve parlementaire
au sein du groupe ump pour faire en
sorte effectivement que ceux qui sont
présents ou très présent au scénar
perçoivent une dotation bien plus
importante que ceux qui n'y sont pas
présents la transparence sur
l'utilisation des moyens du sénat la
certification des comptes des groupes
politiques mais c'est en marche voilà on
s'est effectivement les sujets sur
lesquels il faut travailler je suis
persuadé gérard larcher le tout à fait
conscients de cela et qu'il fera ce
qu'il faut l'allié centriste soutient le
programme de gérard larcher inutile de
relancer le débat sur les réserves
parlementaires la réserve parlementaire
contrairement à ce que certains médias
ont voulu laisser à penser n'a rien de
scandaleux c'est un crédit qui est mis à
disposition des parlementaires pour
aider des projets des collectivités
locales de leur côté les sénateurs de
gauche demandent à modifier en urgence
le règlement du sénat
président larcher est un sénateur
expérimenté donc je pense qu'il a le
désir sincère de faire bouger l'image du
sénat qui est effectivement n'est pas
bonne et depuis quelques depuis quelques
années il y a à s'attaquer de façon très
très concrètes aux problèmes
d'absentéisme
je dirais que s'est développée au sénat
j'ose dire presque une habitude
d'emplois fictifs pour certains
sénateurs et ça ça n'est pas acceptable
pour l'opinion enfin gérard larcher qui
avait estimé que le sénat avait disparu
de tous les écrans radars avec son
prédécesseur jean-pierre bel n'hésite
pas à prendre la parole sur tous les
sujets d'actualité à son agenda beaucoup
de rendez vous médiatiques
dont celui qui nous occupe ensuite
avoir vu des gens me prennent avec nous
notre confrère de l'été alors vos
questions
sur la réforme bonjour monsieur larcher
bonjour michel voilà vous voulez
réformer le sénat vous avez parlé
notamment du sénat hors les murs est ce
que vous avez un exemple concret de ce
ces nord les murs qu'est ce que vous
faites et puis quand et où n'importe
quel est l'intérêt d'aller hors les murs
et d'aller à la rencontre du territoire
des citoyens et des élus et le faire de
manière j'allais dire très très
concrètes le premier exemple qui va être
devant nous c'est la réforme
territoriale et notamment compétences
répartition des compétences entre
communes et intercommunalités
départements et régions le président
philippe bas le nouveau président de la
commission des lois
madic à la mi novembre ils se rendraient
sur le territoire il a sollicité que je
puisse l'accompagner finlande ou encore
ouvrir
ce sera déterminé dans les jours qui
viennent mais ce sera pour parler de la
relation départements régions et
communes ce sera aussi aller la
rencontre des forces vives du territoire
c'est un premier exemple il y en avant
il y en aura d'autres il appartiendra
notamment président de commission à
faire vivre ce sénat qui doit vivent
aussi dans les murs pour pas céder à
l'effet de mode mais aussi est d'aller à
la rencontre du territoire c'est aussi
le message qu'ils nous venu par les
sénateurs nord qui viennent d'être élus
et qu'ils reviennent en quelque sorte
d'une campagne il ya besoin de ce
contact entre une assemblée ça va durer
combien de jours enfin j'ai derrière une
journée rayon pleine journée je vais
vous dire j'avais envie que ça il ya
quelques années quand j'étais président
de la commission des affaires
économiques nous avions mené une partie
du travail préparatoire de la réforme
notamment du système postal hors les
murs du sénat alors on vient d'entendre
madame pts à tasca qui dénonce
l'absentéisme des sénateurs alors
combien d'élus à votre combien de
sénateurs votre avis devraient être
présents pour voter les textes elle a eu
un mot très très dur vous l'avez entendu
très fort
elle a parlé d'emplois fictifs pour
certains je n'utiliserai pas ce mot là
parce que vous connaissez
les cieux prévu très bien le sénat vous
voyez aussi des sénateurs qui
travaillent et qui travaille énormément
qui sont présents qui contribuent
travail travaux en commission nous avons
deux problèmes
nous avons un problème d'abord
d'organisation de trash un da et cette
organisation notre agenda fait que nous
siégeons en commissions et en même temps
nous siégeons en séance et que beaucoup
de nos collègues sont tiraillés entre
les deux activités nous avons aussi un
mode d'examen des textes qui dans la
réforme de 2008 fait que nous avons une
répétition entre les travaux en
commissions et les travaux en séance
publique ce qui rend moins dynamique est
moins intéressant puis nous avons un
problème de votation nous avons un
système de votation qui fait que au
moment du vote sur des textes importants
nous ne sommes pas rassemblés où ces
votes là se déroule à une heure avancée
de la soirée alors
j'ai demandé la mise en place d'un
groupe de travail ceci aura lieu à
partir du 12 novembre
donc très très bientôt cette réforme là
elle devrait préparer de ce que
j'appelle des méthodes de travail du cdh
rivera qu'il ya un nombre minimum de
sénateur et mystique en beauté les
méthodes ou des méthodes de votation qui
feront notamment à l'exemple de
l'assemblée nationale des votes
solennels précédé d'explications de vote
qui permettront par exemple qu'au moins
la moitié des sénateurs puces soient
présents dans dans l'hémicycle au moment
du vote mais je ne ferme pas je pose la
question d'un ensemble de méthodes de
travail du sénat je le confie à mes
collègues
présidents de commission représentant de
chacun des groupes politiques et j'ai
pris la décision de président et moi
même ce groupe de travail pour montrer
l'importance que j'y attache et avec un
délai qui est la fin février alors les
sénateurs qui travaillent on le sait la
ronde c'est incontestable il y en a
aussi qu'on voit très rarement et
quelquefois la meilleure façon de lutter
contre l'absentéisme c'est quand même de
frapper au portefeuille est-ce que vous
envisageriez des sanctions financières
vous avez entendu deux sénateurs
d'allier la réflexion du groupe ump
d'autres groupes envisagent de le faire
ceci fera partie des sujets que nous
mettrons sur la table à l'occasion de ce
groupe vous permet elle vous êtes sujet
tabou et aux sanctions financières jeudi
que celle ci doit être est ce le terme
sanctions dans la modulation modulation
mois délagation parce que le terme
sanction c'est une décision du bureau
c'est très complexe mais attention aux
mots qu'on utilise est en tous les cas
pour moi le présentéisme est quelque
chose d'important je n'irai pas jusqu'au
mot vraiment je redis de catherine tasca
pour qui j'ai amitié et respect emploi
faire mais oui parce que il ne faut pas
jeter
j'allais dire l'eau du sénat ou non de
quelques collègues qui s'affranchissent
d'une présence au sénat je constate
quand même qui a une majorité assez
large de mes collègues qui vraiment sont
à la fois présents sur le territoire
présent au sénat présent aux travaux en
commission mais et demain vont présider
le comité de déontologie du sénat ce que
ça veut dire qu'il ya certains
comportements qui doivent être corrigées
demain nous procédons et s'installe le
comité de déontologie que je quitterais
d'ailleurs avant l'élection de son
président puisque le principe du comité
de déontologie c'est d'examiner il avait
été créé je rappelle à l'initiative de
robert badinter
et de joindre on dit d'examiner toutes
questions d'éthique et de déontologie
relatifs à la vie parlementaire
d'ailleurs la loi de 2013 a fixé les
principes sur notamment des objectifs de
transparence ou de conflit d'intérêts je
pense notamment aux conflits d'intérêts
la consultation du comité de déontologie
je pense que c'est un comité extrêmement
important où nos collègues auront à
examiner des situations pour éclairer le
bureau du sénat le président du sénat ce
que vous avez demandé des comptes aux
sénateurs sur l'utilisation de leurs six
mille euros de frais de représentation
comme ça s'est fait dans n'importe
quelle entreprise
d'abord pour rappeler peut-être
téléspectateurs que la rémunération
parlementaire net c'est un peu plus de
5300 heures voilà ce qui n'est pas une
somme et remercia les 3l il ya cette
enveloppe donc de si mais alors vous
avez là des représentats ti de frais de
mandat qui
est une indemnité qui sert à l'ensemble
des frais à couvrir les frais dudit
mandat cette indemnité elle va avoir
d'autant plus d'importance que dans
moins de deux ans si le texte ne change
pas vous aurez l'application du texte
sur le cumul des mandats est d'ailleurs
un certain nombre déjà tiré les
conséquences de ce texte et ils n'auront
pas la capacité d'avoir d'autres
fonctions dans une collectivité pendant
ces râleurs le sujet de l'indemnité
représentative de frais de mandat
sera dans les travaux que je vais
confier au bureau du sénat
sur la gouvernance il n'y aura pas
simplement ce sujet dit rfm il y aura le
statut des groupes politiques de statuts
de l'association des présidents de
groupe politique le statut aussi
de la réserve parlementaire et de sa
meilleure transparence en publications
je suis favorable à la dotation d'action
parlementaire à la condition que sa
sortie ne soit pas un espèce
d'événements je suis pour l'équité
d'ailleurs quand j'étais président du
sénat c'est moi qui a engagé cette
réforme le président bayle a poursuivi
cette réforme vers plus de transparence
je crois qu'il faut lâcher alors arrêtez
vos documents qu'ils soient tout à fait
différent de celui qu'on a publi jeu
semaines avant les élections
sénatoriales et qui monsieur prévost
bien je le souhaite sergent louis
prévost et nous verrons les conclusions
et en tous les cas j'ai indique que déjà
sur
les dossiers on peut assez facilement
assez facilement
construire en fait la liste les
opérations mais je souhaiterais un
document simple qui démontre qu'on a
aucune gêne à dire qu'on a et d une
commune dans lequel il ya une inondation
entend lever rendre à l'exemple récent
qui est l'exemple du gard des
inondations terribles vous avez les
communes rurales pour qui dix mille
euros leur permet de remettre en état la
mairie la salle polyvalente et il ya une
vraie légitimité à la dotation d'action
parlementaire qui al'avantage d'être
sous le contrôle des préfets ça n'est
pas la cassette du sénateur et d'être
extrêmement réactif à l'heure donc on le
voit il ya un grand chantier ouvert donc
pour contre l'absentéisme
pour la transparence ça veut dire que
vous êtes obligés de prendre des mesures
radicales pour rendre le sénat
irréprochable afin qu'ils ne soient pas
de ballet ni les mesures le mot radical
je prendre des mesures collégiale parce
que c'est tous ensemble que nous avons
la responsabilité de jeanne senaya pas
simplement le président n'a pas
simplement le bureau nous sommes 348 à
être responsable d'une institution
quelle je crois je crois profondément au
bicamérisme je crois au bicamérisme dans
une république qui va mal la solution à
balancier ce qu'il faut sauver ce
système il est maire que je pense que
dans les périodes de crise le parlement
est toujours mis en cause et que dans
les périodes de crise le parlement se
doit d'être encore plus exigeants
vis-à-vis de lui-même pour reconquérir
la confiance des français nous avons un
problème aujourd'hui seuls les maires
les maires adjoints les conseillers
municipaux la confiance majoritaire des
français et nous qui sommes les élus de
ces élus là je pense que nous pouvons
reconquérir cette confiance est dans une
démocratie la confiance dans les
politiques est quelque chose d'essentiel
alors on va parler peut-être des
réformes qui viennent le sénat vient de
tu es la réforme territoriale en seconde
lecture vous croyez qu'elle va vraiment
se faire cette réforme je pense le
premier ministre et là je dois dire
président de la république alors mercier
a répondu à ma demande de remettre en
perspective la région territoriale
c'était indispensable pour tout le monde
nous avons eu des débats qui ont été des
débats à la fois fort nous proposons une
carte régionale mais pas simplement nous
avons réaffirmé et le premier ministre
dit un verre sur la question du
département sur une intercommunalité que
l'égalité sur des régions stratège donc
la réforme territoriale nous allons en
débattre à partir du 16 décembre c'est à
dire dans un mois et demi nous ouvrirons
le dossier qui nous suivent sans doute
que nous aurions dû ouvrir en premier
quels dossiers des compétences à vous
êtes sûr que cette soirée jour justement
sur le nombre des régions manuel valls
est quand même prononcé pour la carte
des 13 régions qui avait été voté pour
l'adhésion ce sera
la pression négative excusez moi la
commission mixte paritaire jargonne très
vite et
est ce que vous pensez que cette réforme
se fera par exemple il ya certains élus
qui en d'autres mains françois bayrou il
est persuadé que ça ne se fera pas par
exemple l'a tellement de la région ce
sera dans nos débats de décembre et 2
janvier
car c'est sur la question des
compétences qui fait quoi
car la grande faute du gouvernement
ayrault
ça a été de rétablir la compétence
générale pour les régions que les
départements c'est la principale source
notamment de maîtrise de la dépense
publique et donc moi j'attends un
gouvernement
et je pense qu'il ne sera ouvert aux
débats du sénat en première lecture à
partir du 16 décembre où nous aurons la
discussion générale puis début janvier
quand nous disputerons 1 0 aujourd'hui
la semaine prochaine le sénat s'était qu
aux économies de la sécurité sociale
vous allez revenir sur la modulation des
allocations moi je crois à
l'universalité de cette des allocations
familiales et je crois qu'il y à
d'autres mesures je pense à l'allocation
parent isolé pour corriger les
déséquilibres
où les inégalités sociales donc je pense
que c'est un point sur lequel la
commission reviendront de même que la
commission fera un certain nombre de
propositions pour maîtriser la dépense
et puis il faudra bien un jour qu'on
lance une vraie réflexion sur la
sécurité sociale est ce qu'on peut
continuer à avoir un système dual d'un
côté de l'état de l'autre côté la
sécurité sociale toutes ces réflexions
cd réflexion à plus long terme mais la
domination des locaux
je suis défavorable très bien voilà
c'est clair est dit très clairement dit
et on va évoquer avec vous l'ump votre
parti l'ump qui n'a plus que quelques
mois à vivre si nicolas sarkozy mais son
projet en oeuvre mais il est bien décidé
semble-t-il louis ses billes
cinq noms différents 50 ans rpf hubert
rpr ump la droite est championne tout
catégorie des changement de sigle de son
parti
très souvent c'est pour mieux lier le
parti un homme providentiel eh bien
nicolas sarkozy ne déroge pas à la règle
et me faire table rase du passé une fois
élu si vous ne soit si c'est dans les
trois mois nous créerons les conditions
du plus vaste rassemblement que notre
pays aura jamais connu nouvelle méthode
nouvelle équipe nouveau projet nouveau
mode fonctionnement changer de fond en
comble changer de marque c'est vouloir
tourner la page des guerres intestines
de copé et fillon et des récents
scandales qui ont éclaboussé l'ump à
faire bygmalion en tête vous ne pouvez
donner un sentiment de nouveauté qu'en
changeant tout le reste quand vous même
vous avez déjà été président de l'ump et
président de la république il est
tellement sortant il est tellement avant
qu'il faut changer absolument tout pour
donner l'impression que c'est un
renouveau opération rénovation pour
aussi faire disparaître les différents
courants au sein de la droite le mot
rassemblement revient sans cesse dans la
bouche de nicolas sarkozy seulement dans
la course à la tête de l'ump les
différentes écuries ne sont pas d'accord
hervé mariton alain juppé ou encore
bruno le maire ne veulent pas changer
deux nuls j'ai plutôt tendance à dire
qu'il faut une famille politique
s'installe dans la durée survivent aux
épreuves aux difficultés et qu'elle est
d'autant plus forte si elle sait
s'installer dans le temps moi ce qui
m'importe de l'avion c'est l'adn de
l'ump l'adn de l'ump c'est un parti de
centre
c'est un parti de droite c'est un parti
qui réunit différentes familles
politiques un nouveau nom pour une
machine de guerre électorale
rassemblement peuple france le
vocabulaire semble maintenant un peu
épuisé si sarkozy est élu à la tête de
l'ump il attendra les élections de mars
prochain pour changer selon ses mots le
parti du sol au plafond
voilà
sur la situation
bon l'ump a traversé une période très
difficile et j'allais dire
courageusement la juppé jean pierre
raffarin françois fillon avec luc chatel
assure la préparation d'un congrès qui
nous permettra de choisir un président
mais derrière il faudra reconstruire un
projet
revisiter les valeurs qui nous a laissé
construire l'ump faire pardonner mois le
nom ne serait que la conséquence moi je
viens d'entendre eric ciotti est pour
moi le nom n'est pas l'acte central
l'acte central c'est au tour de quel
projet autour de quelles valeurs nous
préparons un projet d'alternance que
nous proposons français
qui se focalise sur le parti
l'affrontement copé sion puis il a fait
un big maliens n'ont pas laisser de
telles traces dans l'opinion publique il
faudrait finalement tout ripoliné tout
revoir je pense que l'opinion publique
se moque assez peu du ripolin et qu'il
préférait plutôt qu un enduit retrouver
les fondamentaux
c'est comme dans le bâtiment et les
fondamentaux sait quelles sont les
valeurs qui nous ont rassemblés nous ne
sommes pas dans la situation de 2002
nous sommes même pas dans la situation
de 2007 nous sommes dans un pays en
crise dans un pays qui a besoin de
réformes dans un pays qui n'est plus
capable d'équilibrer son budget dans un
pays qui n'est plus capable d'assurer
septembre cet adage est à l'ump impôts
et moi personnellement je pense que
c'est ça qu'il faut que nous répondions
et c'est un peu ce à quoi nous nous
attachions c'est pas un coup politique
c'est vraiment retrouver la confiance
des français dans le ravalement de
façade c'est quand même le bureau
national de l'ump ce soir avec sur la
table juste après cette émission
l'exclusion ou non de jérôme lavrilleux
de l'ump vous allez voter quoi c'est pas
un ravalement si je peux me permettre
c'est une clarification
jérôme lavrilleux deux ans les caméras
de vos confrères a dit qu'il avait été
aux jaloux diraient au centre je ne sais
pas mais dans un système de fausse
facturation
c'est contraire à l'éthique et aux
principes qui doivent j'allais dire et
régler un parti politique comme derrière
une entreprise personnellement parce que
je fait que le vote est public et parce
que j'ai assisté à d'autres exclusions
coup il va être sais pas mais moi perso
zahlé aujourd'hui typiquement oui que je
considère que jérôme lavrilleux n'a pas
sa place à l'ump est ce que vous avez
demandé à ce que ça va très public à ce
jeu sera sans doute demandé mais si je
suis encore présent à cette heure là je
le demanderai d'accord nicolas sarkozy
veut aussi faire des pas disparaître au
sein de l'ump les courants les chapelles
se dire qu'il n'y aura plus qu'un seul
chef est ce que ça vous semble une bonne
sono moi je n'ai jamais été favorable au
courant ou chapelles parce que
rassemblement c'est pas une addition de
deux chapelles ou petite église c'est un
projet qui respecte la diversité des
sensibilités et qui un moment propose
une synthèse aux français moi je me sens
gaulliste je suis attaché aux
institutions je me méfie d'ailleurs de
toutes les propositions y compris chez
mes amis je bois en permanence remis en
cause un certain nombre de principes
institutionnels de la vème république
et bien c'est un sujet majeur pour moi
quand j'entends parler de réforme des
institutions je dis souvent c'est pour
masquer notre incapacité à réformer
notre pays
par avion je ne suis pas sûr que le
sujet du nombre de parlementaires sur le
sujet sans trail des français
aujourd'hui je suis en train des
français
c'est pas une proposition de chercher je
n'ai pas une proposition de gérard
marché ça ne peut être que la
conséquence d'une réflexion qu'il
approche institutionnelle
si vous commencez à dire il y en a deux
centraux et bien sans vous êtes posé la
question qu'est ce que le parlement quel
est son rôle alors quel est son pouvoir
pardonnez moi vous fait plaisir car ils
sont les a tous les ténors mais ils se
font plaisir il rappelé tout à fait l'ex
prison de gand des ventes hiver vous
demande de me le dise dos c'est pas
parce qu'il le dise tout ce que je vous
dis que c'est pour moi l'alpha et
l'oméga de la réforme je ne dis pas
qu'il ne faut pas à un moment réduire le
nombre de parlementaires et l'adapter je
dis que ça n'est que la conséquence
d'une réflexion collective sur un projet
politique et une éventuelle réforme
institutionnelle qui doit respecter les
fondamentaux et je vous le dis où en
serait monsieur hollande et monsieur
valls ont des institutions de la vème
république avec les alliés qu'ils ont
aujourd'hui nous serions dans une crise
politique extrêmement profonde avant de
toucher aux institutions de la vème ya
déjà beaucoup trop touchés je pense
qu'il faut le faire d'une main
tremblante mais quand rien sur la
proportionnelle par exemple et bien sûr
parce que qu'elle est d'abord la
première question dans la confiance
entre les citoyens et leurs élus c'est
que l'élu au scrutin majoritaire c'est
un élu connu choisi regardez le statut
des conseillers régionaux je les ai été
très peu connu
les statuts d'un conseiller
départemental vais faire moderne ancien
conseiller général qui lui ait lieu au
scrutin majoritaire il est connu
identifier un député élu à partir d'une
liste d'une liste à la proportionnelle
c'est faire courir un risque
d'éloignement supplémentaires je suis
donc attaché au scrutin très majoritaire
verra parce que peut-être que françois
hollande va avancer des propositions en
ce sens contraire jeudi soir
sous la présidence de l'ump la course à
la présidence de l'ump est ce que
nicolas sarkozy reste le favori je pense
que nicolas sarkozy a à un acquis
important d'abord il a déjà présidé
l'ump est il un capital et un stock de
sympathie à l'intérieur de l'ump j'ai
dit très clairement personnellement que
je me prenait parti pour aucun des trois
ne sait pas encore ce soit pour lier ces
deux semaines je me rendrai à des
réunions des trois candidats c'est aussi
mon rôle
je travaillerai avec celui qui sera élu
mais j'y travaillerai avec mon approche
personnelle on approche collective comme
président du sénat pour moi le sénat est
une institution de la république l'ump
est un parti et ce parti politique il
est indispensable l'expression de la
démocratie mais je fais bien la
distinction truc qui est un homme de
terrain gérard larcher comment vous
sentez les choses est ce que nicolas
sarkozy reste le grand favori ou alors
on parle de surprise on dit que beaucoup
que bruno le maire fait une très bonne
campagne d'or table adore mais de la
compétition je pense que bruno le maire
mais on parle pas beaucoup de d'hervé
mariton ils avancent des idées il avance
des convictions et que au bout du compte
si nous savons nous rassembler au delà
du 29 novembre le débat qui a eu lieu
entre les trois n'aura pas été inutile
pour revitaliser l'ump sarkozy ce serait
quoi on va coûter la tout à l'heure je
te relèves
de météo je ne vais pas vous donner la
température on va
mettre non je ne vis pas avec un
baromètre c'est pas mon style vous savez
je suis tout paysan les gens regardent
d'abord le temps qui fait vraiment en
parler vous avez parlé d' absentéisme
tout à l'heure françois fillon il est
très silencieux est ce qu'il n'est pas
trop absents de ce débat là
quand fillon qu'il est
le seul aujourd'hui avoir fait un
certain nombre de propositions très
concrètes sur l'éducation sur la
compétitivité cette semaine il
présentera notamment des propositions
sur l'immigration non des propositions
pour l'alternance n'est pas absent des
écrans radar 17 après il a le choix qui
est le sien il n'a pas souhaité se mêler
de l'élection à l'ump d'ailleurs ça peut
gommer tous ceux qui disaient que la
période qui est assez injuste entre
jean-françois copé et françois fillon
parce qu en fait celui qui disait la
vérité cd france ou six ans
alain juppé est ce que c'est l'homme
providentiel maintenant à droite et je
ne crois pardonnez moi pour des raisons
philosophiques est balisé philosophique
politique et éthique je ne crois jamais
à la providence je crois je crois que
alain juppé fait partie des hommes dans
notre pays a besoin et que nous avons de
la chance d'avoir un homme comme alain
juppé comme nous avons la chance d'avoir
d'autres hommes d'autres femmes et alain
juppé c'est du solide et et c'est un
homme dont j'allais dire le pays
pourrait avoir besoin le moment venu je
regarde avec beaucoup de respect sa
démarche quelle différence vous diriez
vous verriez vous entre finalement
nicolas sarkozy françois fillon alain
juppé quand on regarde précisément
ils se ressemblent n'y a pas de fracture
d'abord nous connaissons pas les projets
chaque chose viendra en son temps elle à
des silhouettes 9 novembre c'est
l'élection la présidence de l'ump et
vous avez trois compétiteurs qui ont des
propositions pour un parti politique en
2016 vous aurez une primaire et vous
aurez des propositions d'ailleurs alain
juppé n'a pas encore avancer son projet
il l'a confié à hervé gaymard qui est
quelqu'un de qualité
françois fillon avance des éléments du
projet il n'a pas donné totalement il y
aura la primaire nous
regarderons et accompagneront la
primaire et puis un candidat qui sera
choisi et j'espère que le candidat
choisi son rang l'a20 le vainqueur du
grand challenge devant les français que
l'élection à la présidence de l'umih dit
ce n'est pas parce que si l'ump
disparaît et bien la haute autorité des
primaires ne disparaissent également à
la haute autorité des primaires c'est un
sujet dans la transformation du mp jeudi
à chacun de ceux qui ont été candidats
que ça a été le point sur lequel nous
avons pu trouver une sortie de la très
grave crise chacun doit mesurer que
l'engagement des primaires c'est pas
simplement un engagement sur un bout de
papier c'est un engagement moral et
politique et ça compte on parle beaucoup
d'alliance avec le centre comment vous
traduisez vous est ce que c'est une
alliance électorale avec le centre ou
alors est-ce que c'est une fusion avec
le centre comme le souhaiterait vraiment
nicolas sarkozy encore lui
il ya quelques mois là encore sur votre
plateau j'ai dit que je ne croyais pas
la fusion réduction avec le centre je ne
croyais pas loupé à je pense qu'il
existe dans notre pays
une op 1 je ne dis pas qu'il a déclenché
je pense personnellement que le centre a
une existence politique et on le vérifie
au céda il gère des centristes à l'ump
et les centristes en dehors de l'ump
c'est pas du tout incompatible je pense
moi personnellement que c'est une
richesse à la condition que nous
sachions nous organiser parce que
l'élection présidentielle est un moment
où il faut bien mesurer les enjeux par
rapport au populisme au pluriel ambiant
et c'est vrai pour le parti socialiste
comme c'est vrai pour nos familles
politiques comment vous êtes un point
important voilà pourquoi personnellement
je suis plutôt pour des primaires
ouvertes des primaires et comment est ce
que vous réagissez aux fêtes aujourd'hui
vous l'avez vu dans les sondages c'est
marine le pen qui apparaît comme la
première opposante à françois hollande
eh bien ça nous donne une responsabilité
nous qui sommes engagés dans des partis
politiques républicains d'alternance ou
ne pas faire n'importe quoi ne pas céder
à nos pulsions d'avoir un vrai projet et
de répondre aux inquiétudes des français
c'est ça si c'est pour faire des coups
politiques les uns ou les autres
pardonnez moi les français ne nous
feront plus confiance ma première
préoccupation c'est de retrouver le
chemin de la confiance avec les français
et c'est la tâche à laquelle nous nous
appelons au sénat collectivement très
bien merci beaucoup gérard larcher merci
pérenne bonsoir à tous et merci de
moralité mardi prochain c'est l'euro
novembre ne sera pas la perrine l'on se
retrouve dans 15 jours avec un nouvel
invité le 18 bonsoir à tous et à très
vite